[Musique]
manuel Mathieu vous êtes une des
vedettes du monde de l'art contemporain
on se trouve à votre nouvelle exposition
sur la mélancolie qu'est-ce que vous
voulez exprimer avec toutes ces formes
tous ces mouvements
et ces formes-là mais reflète mon esprit
déjà on va commencer par ça et
je cherche je sais pas je me considère
comme un chercheur qui qui tombe sur des
choses et qu'il les ramène de notre
réalité en fait votre histoire est
vraiment fascinante parce que vous êtes
né en Haïti puis à 15 ans votre oncle
vous a initié alors à 19 ans vous êtes
débarqué à Montréal ça va grand-mère qui
a vécu sous le régime de Jean-Claude
Duvalier et c'est elle qui vous
encouragez d'une certaine façon parce
que c'est pas ce que vos parents
voulaient là ouais mais pas faut
comprendre que j'étais un enfant
difficile
adolescent très adolescent on va dire
donc mes parents ils avaient peur en
fait il me contrôlait plus mes parents
donc quand je suis arrivé ici puis j'ai
laissé ici c'était comme un soulagement
pour et quand je suis arrivé même ma
grand-mère était là pour nous recevoir
plusieurs masseurs étaient déjà là je
pense avec mon cousin donc c'est dans ce
contexte là elle elle m'a pas posé de
questions en fait on m'a juste supporté
dans qui je voulais devenir
comment un adolescent difficile réussit
à faire une maîtrise à Londres et avoir
un succès qu'il connaît aujourd'hui mais
c'est que l'adolescent arrêté d'être une
adolescent il est devenu un homme qui a
vécu des choses qui a certainement cassé
des œufs sur son chemin mais qui est qui
a évolué et qui est devenu quelqu'un de
pas dire raisonnable mais quelqu'un qui
qui a qui a un rêve
il y a un événement qui a vraiment
changé votre pratique artistique c'est
cet accident de moto il y a un délit de
fuite dans cette affaire là tu es
presque perdu la vie
comment comment ça s'est passé pour vous
ce changement là parce que vous êtes
bien vous intéresser à la solitude par
la suite ou c'est à l'amnésie oui oui ma
grand-mère était en train de mourir par
la même époque le cancer donc ça m'a
donné un petit peu du ça a permis de me
rapprocher d'elle déjà parce que j'étais
en train de pendant qu'elle était en
train de disparaître moi j'étais en
train de reprendre possession de mes de
mon esprit au fait et ça m'a fait me
poser des questions sur son histoire
réelle sur l'histoire de mon pays sur
l'histoire de sur la question que je me
posais mais que j'avais pas de réponse
comme pourquoi est-ce que j'étais exposé
à autant de violence en grandissant en
Haïti puis j'ai compris qu'on était ma
génération la première génération qui
sort de la dictature moi j'ai 35 ans je
suis né en 86 c'est la date de la fin de
la dictature donc on est la première
génération de jeunes de 30 ans et plus
qui
d'adultes au fait donc c'est dans ce
contexte là que que je me suis dit mais
je veux travailler là-dessus
expliquez-moi votre ascension parce que
vous avez 35 ans mais en très peu de
temps vous êtes vraiment devenu vedette
dans le monde de leur contemporain vous
vendez beaucoup de toiles à plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de dollars
avez-vous l'impression de vivre un
compte de fait parce qu'il y a très peu
d'artistes en arts visuel contemporain
qui réussissent comme vous réussissez je
suis d'accord je dirais pas que c'est
c'est
conte de fées je pense que qu'est-ce que
c'est c'est définitivement un rodéo si
on veut parce que c'est c'est
foisonnant c'est aussi
nouveau parce qu'on a on parle de mon
succès comme si que j'étais totalement
contrôlé de ce qui se passe mais c'est
beaucoup de nouveautés par exemple parce
que au fur et à mesure que les gens
commencent à s'habituer à qui je suis en
peintre ou en tant qu'artiste moi je
suis en train de me multiplier dans
d'autres domaines donc je suis toujours
on parlait de d'adolescence tout à
l'heure je suis toujours dans un espace
de nouveautés de régénérer je régénérer
ça qui fait que je ne peut-être que je
ne réalise pas que c'est un conte de feu
en tant que mon relais vous devez être
fier parce que vous avez été choisi pour
créer 5 mosaïques pour le réseau express
métropolitain oui le rêve
quelle nouvelle écoutez ça ça
cette nouvelle est tellement
inimaginable pour moi parce que moi
quand je suis arrivé ici j'étais à
Blainville puis j'ai étudié au HEC
j'allais wash aussi pour étudier donc
c'est la station est-ce que je
m'arrêtais donc mon petit ou université
de Montréal pour moi c'est une scène
imaginable au fait de pouvoir
d'avoir un impact aussi énorme dans la
dans la société qui m'a vu grandir c'est
c'est un imaginable je trouve ça que je
suis très content de reconnaissant
manuel Mathieu vous devez me quitter
parce que vous partez pour la France
pour 6 mois oui bon voyage merci pour
l'entrevue merci ça fait plaisir
[Musique]